[MUSIC]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I wanna tell you how America still works
and, maybe give you some tips.
I had to start a variety businesses with
little or no money.
But she had touched upon one thing in high
school.
I was in a high school class with my
friend Michelle Gillian, and I sat in
front of Michelle.
And we were at 11th grade, we would pass
notes back and forth, so we were really
clever.
She sat behind me so, I would like, write
a little note.
Put it in like, like that, you know, lean
back, and she grabbed it.
Well one day mister Wax, intercepted our
note, and read it to the whole class.
Oh, this Johnny guy and this Michelle, I'm
gonna read the note.
Some stupid like see you at [UNKNOWN] you
know, after
school you know Darlene [UNKNOWN] and Ron
were gonna be there.
Something really, really silly, you know,
we're just buddies.
It said, they will never amount to
anything.
Well, Michelle Gillian two days later, I
should say two
years later, became Michelle Phillips of
the Mamas and Papas,
whose an actress, was the superstar, and
so forth, so,
on my 50th birthday, Michelle and I have
always remained friends.
She went and found Mister Wax, and brought
him to a place to called
El Cholo, in L.A., a place we go to for
dinner after, in high school.
Brought him there, and we reminded him of
the situation.
[LAUGH] And well, I don't know.
[LAUGH] I wanna tell you that, America
works, America works really, really well.
And the rest of the world is following,
regardless of the publicity, that some
people put out.
Yeah, there are some things wrong with our
country.
But boy, we're straightening them out
really quick.
We the people, are taking over.
In life, you're gonna see things, that you
think
are real, or read things that you think
are real.
Sometimes they are, and sometimes they're
not.
What is very real is that, the economy
you're in
today, is not what the press makes it out
to be.
I'll give you an example.
In 1980, when I started John Paul
Mitchell Systems with my partner,
inflation was 12.5%.
What is it now, 1%?
Interest rates were 18%.
What's it now, four, five, six, 7%?
Unemployment was 10.5%, and you had to
wait in
line, for sometimes blocks at a time, to
get gasoline.
You know, actually, most of you weren't
even born
then, but that's how it was, it really,
really was.
It was a lot worse than this today, but
yet people say look how bad the economy
is.
Maybe not the best time to start a
business.
In 1980, we started John Paul Mitchell
Systems with $700.
That's it, no loans.
Today it is probably the largest
independently
owned hair care professional company in
America.
And growing, we're in 87 countries
throughout the world, and growing quite
rapidly.
But America does work, and our way of
doing things works.
No matter whether you agree with the
politicians, you don't
agree with the politicians, look around
the world a little bit.
Why the uprising in Tunisia?
Why do you have uprises in Egypt, where
they didn't before?
And all of sudden, in Iran they're saying,
wait
a minute, you know, we threw the shah out.
Mullahs, you're not doing any better.
You know, we want you.
Why is this going on?
Well obviously, as most of you know, we're
the technological age, where they have
email, they have
twitter, they have everything you could
ever imagine,
so they know what's going on in the world.
More people in the world, want
deservingly, a better chance,
a better opportunity, to at least have the
opportunity for
a better life, and they're watching it
now, what's going
on throughout the world and saying well,
that's not so bad.
Maybe these bad guys aren't really that
bad.
Maybe what's going on in America.
Where, we the people.
Hey, Obama came in.
Man that guy gave great speeches.
I thought wow, I don't believe this guy.
He's gonna knock out immediately pork
barrow spending.
It's gonna be gone.
He said he would in the election.
Let's go for this guy.
Yey, finally someone's gonna do something!
All of a sudden, every bill that went
through, had pork barrel spending.
So what did we the people do?
We didnt' wait four years.
Two years later, we started kicking out
democrats and putting in more republicans
or, independents.
Because, we the people are speaking up.
We the people don't want anymore.
All of a sudden, republican party jumps in
and says, op, were
gonna stop pork barrel spending, even
though it's been going on for years.
We didn't do it during our administration,
but were gonna
do it now, because Obama said he would and
didn't.
It's politics.
But the end result of politics is, things
are changed.
They are getting better.
I wanna share with you, how to start a
business, with little
to no money, using Paul Mitchell as a
great example of this.
And then also go into a few of the other
things we do, and maybe some real secrets
to success.
Wanna start with two things.
It's the most asked questions of me.
John Paul.
What is the main, main thing we should
know, to be successful in anything we do?
And is there a second one?
And I'll tell you those right off the
that.
The first one is this, and I'll explain
it.
Be prepared for rejection.
Be prepared for a lot of rejection.
I don't care how good your idea is, no
matter how unique it is.
You're gonna be knocking on doors, or
talking to
people, to sell your services, or sell
your product.
And you're gonna get a lot of rejection.
You, if you're aware of it in advance, it
won't be
like, wow, this is not a good idea, 20
people said no.
You have to be able to knock on door
number 100, and be just as enthusiastic
on that door, as you were on the first 100
doors that were slammed in your face.
Be prepared in advance for rejection.
I sold encyclopedias door to door, when I
was
19, 20, 21, and 22 years old, for
Collier's Encyclopedia.
I believed, everyone needed a Collier's
Encyclopedia.
A high school student could understand it.
A college student could tolerate it okay.
May not be Britannica, but was, everyone
needed one.
So I sold them door to door.
No appointments, just went out there
knocking on doors.
And all of a sudden, if they let me
in, all these bindings red and blue would
come out.
But I believe what I did was right.
I had a lot of rejection.
Doors slammed in my face, all the time.
And people, they weren't very courteous.
But then again, I was calling on their
homes, in
the late afternoon, throughout the
evening, I wasn't expected there anyways.
The average encyclopedia salesman in those
days, lasted three days.
I lasted four years, and then I got out.
Commission only.
But, one of the things I learned was,
belief, if
you believe what you're doing is right,
don't give up.
The successful people, do all the things
the unsuccessful people don't want to do.
That's number two.
Successful people do all the things
unsuccessful people don't want to do.
Like a door number 101 smiling.
And being enthusiastic.
Not giving up on what you're doing, and
being really into it.
I wanna give you, that's phase one.
Part one and part two.
The other secret to success, its own
category,
is whatever service, whatever product you
are selling.
Make sure, it's of the highest quality, in
its category, you could possibly have.
You do not want to, and I would underline
do not, you do not want to be in the
selling business, as most everybody does,
I wanna sell my
service, I wanna sell my product, you
don't want that.
The big secret is, you wanna set up
your business, so you're in the reorder
business.
Your service or your product is so darn
good, that people are gonna
want it again, or tell other people, you
gotta get this, it's that cool.
That's how you build a business.
You start in the beginning saying, it's
gonna be
so good, that I'm gonna be in the reorder
business.
People are gonna wanna talk about me.
People are gonna wanna say, this is great.
How do you start a major cosmetic company,
30 years ago, during the worst economy of
the
United States, and it's the great
depression, the
real worst economy since the great
depression, with $700?
Well, we thought it was impossible.
I had my partner who was a hairdresser.
His name was Cyril Thomas Mitchell.
He used the name Paul Mitchell, as his
hairdressing name.
And Jean Paul DeJoria, John Paul Mitchell
Systems.
That's where we got that name together.
And I was from the business end, the
marketing end.
And a little, I knew a little bit about
product formulation.
And my partner was a great hairdresser.
Like one of the most avant garde ones you
can imagine.
He knew products.
He could us them.
So I said, Paul, I've been in the industry
myself, as an executive.
And I said, why don't you and I start a
company together?
I'll raise the $500,000 we need, and
you'll own
30%, I'll own 30%, and the money will own
40%.
We had an investor.
From the tax free haven of Jersey, between
England and France.
And Dick Holpauch with City Corps, set it
up for me, he was a friend of mine.
And then it was all set to go.
And that day, I wasn't getting along with
my wife, wanted to get out of there
anyways.
I left her whatever money I have, left her
the house, a nice car with my daughter,
plenty of
money for a few months, you know, and, put
a
few 100 bucks in my pocket, jumped in my
car.
And went down to the bank.
My partner Paul came over.
He was out of money too.
So he came on over, so we'll get our
$500,000 then
Paul, here's a few thousand for you, I'm
gonna rent an
efficiency hotel or apartment for a week
or two, month, til
I see where I want to situate myself, and
we're in business.
The money never came in.
That night the money still never came in.
What are we gonna do?
Dick [UNKNOWN] got a hold of me, through a
friend of mine.
And so [INAUDIBLE] to JP, it's three in
the morning in England, when HE
finally get a hold of me, and it's the
evening, the banks are closed.
So I don't know how to tell you this JP,
but I just have to.
The backer pulled out.
He says inflation is such and such in
the United States, 12.5% interest rates
are sev, 18%.
Unemployment is 10.5%.
There's a, fuel shortage going on.
And your hostages, there's over four of
them still in Iran that they're holding.
They're not released yet.
I can't invest in the United States where
there.
Oh my God, no money, great idea.
I already set up the bottle man.
I set up the silk screener.
I set up everything to just pull the
trigger and go.
We didn't have any money.
How do you start a business with zero
money?
So I'm gonna give you everything we did.
We didn't have an office.
But, I had a friend with a telephone.
My office, was an answering machine that
you could buy today for $29.95.
I got a friend of mine who had an English
accent.
And she said, hello, John Paul Mitchell
Systems.
Aah!
We're so busy, but leave a message, we'll
get with you.
It looked like we were bigger, there was
just Paul and I.
That was our office, we needed a location,
I went to Universal City,
California, to the little post office
there, for $15, I got a P.O. Box.
John Paul Mitchell Systems, P.O. Box
10597, Universal City, California.
We had a phone.
We had a secretary, didn't exis, there was
someone answering the phone.
That was it.
For stationary, I would go to a print
shop.
For $3, they would typeset, and make me
one copy.
That was my stationary.
I would go to a photocopy place for four
cents a copy,
and make many copies, and now I had
stationary, and I had letterhead.
And I could draw on there, an invoice, I
could invoice people.
Okay, fine.
You have a make believe office set up, but
how about the products?
Well, everyone was set up to do a 100,000
of each bottle.
And you know, they were excited, they were
enthusiastic, we were enthusiastic, I was
excited and enthusiastic.
But nobody knew we didn't have any money.
We didn't wanna lie, but we didn't wanna
quite tell them everything.
So I called up the silk screen, the bottle
man, gotta start with the bottle guy and
said.
Instead of ordering 100,000, bottles I'd
like to have a sample run of 10,000.
Oh, of course, we understand, no problem,
we'll give it to you at the same price.
Called the silk screener, 10,000 are
coming over.
And, it's a sample run, I want 300 shampoo
one, 300 shampoo two,
and I mean 3000, and then I want the other
4000, the conditioner.
No problem.
And by the way, don't put the color on,
because color
was seven cents a pass, black and white
was two cents.
So our bottles came out black and white.
It turned out, it was great, unisex, we
didn't know that.
We just knew it was a lot less to silk
screen them.
Called the filler up.
You get all the supplies, we just need
10,000 filled.
3,000 of this, 3,000 of that.
Okay, and all a sudden, bingo.
The clock started ticking.
From the time the silk screener, got it, I
mean the bottle guy got it to
the silk screener, got it to the filling
house, we had them full, was two weeks.
It was two weeks longer.
Cuz I'd set up credit with everybody,
prior to this time, 30 day credit.
Two weeks from now, that first bill is
due.
I hit the streets, knocking door to door,
like I was selling encyclopedias,
but I would go from beauty salon, to
beauty salon, to beauty salon.
We had a shampoo, that instead of using
two shampoos.
More product, rinsing it down the sink,
you know, it goes away.
You only need one shampoo.
Saves you time and money.
Our conditioner, you didn't put it in the
hair, in
the salon, leave it for ten minutes, rinse
it off.
You take the customer to the station, you
sit them down.
You put the conditioner in your hands, you
show them.
You run it through their hair, and leave
it.
And, you tell your customer, this is
a moisture treatment, this is a protein
treatment.
It's gonna let me cut your hair easier.
And, when I blow dry it, it's gonna cause
less damage to your hair.
Cuz, it's a protector.
So, we knew that.
And, by the way, hairdresser, when you put
it
in your hand, and you do this, every time.
It neutralizes all the chemicals in your
hand.
So, I would go in and give a presentation,
here's my project.
Most people would say, well, why do I need
your product?
You know, I've got Zotos, I've got
L'oreal, I've got
Redken, they go down all the, you know,
regular companies lines.
I don't need your product, you're unknown.
I say, well, here's what I'll do.
If you will agree, to take one dozen each
of what I have, and use my shampoo and
conditioner
at every station you have, I'll make this
agreement with
you, and display it, by the way, to eye
level.
Black and white looks so good at eye
If you will do that, and you are not
satisfied, that's one of the hottest
products you've ever used.
And recommend to your customers to take
home.
I will come back, take every bottle off
the
shelf, you have not used or sold out the
door.
Still a good bottle, we haven't used or
sold yet.
I will give your money back, on all of it.
Now, is that fair enough?
The answer was usually, no we don't need
your product, okay.
[LAUGH] We've all this other products here
right.
[LAUGH] Finally I'd say okay, I can
understand
your scepticism, but if it works the way
it
says it does, and your customers love it
and you love it, you're gonna wanna
recommend it.
I'll tell you what I'll do.
If you will agree, tab it at eye-level on
a nice little display, let me
come in and hold the look class for your
stylist and how to use it.
I will place only six bottles, on the
shampoo six bottles of the conditioner you
know
of everything in your salon and I'll also
give you this within one month 30 days.
If you're not totally happy anything you
haven't used or sold out
the door I'll give you your money back is
that fair enough?
And the same with your customers.
And, someone say yes and some would say
no, and I would say, okay I can
understand.
If I only gave you two bottles, [LAUGH]
and it's
amazing how you can only fit two bottles
or six bottles.
I went around and I got 12 people to buy
it.
Hide it in my trunk so I took it out,
here's your order.
Can I have the check?
[LAUGH] They gave me the check.
I went down to Paris [UNKNOWN] Beauty
Supply
in downtown LA, who was calling on salons.
And I said, would you like to be the
distributor for this new hot-line.
We call it Paul Mitchell because my
partner is a hair dresser, I'm not.
It will only be in the hair dressing
industry forever.
It's not going to be like Nexus or
Jerramac
or all those other companies that sell you
out.
They let the hair dressers build them up
and then they
go retail with there lines, It will always
stay in salons.
so, that's why you should buy our product
here's how unique it is.
He said, we don't need to buy your
product,
we have Elaine Curtis, he just went on and
on.
I said, but I'll tell you what.
If you knew customers were gonna buy this,
would you take it on?
Yeah, but who knows that?
You don't know for sure.
I whipped out twelve orders, put twelve
checks right in front of them
and said that's your first 12 orders and
there's the checks for them.
I haven't cashed them yet.
For $2,000 [LAUGH] in product, you could
be my LA distributer
exclusively for all of LA County and I'll
come in here and help you sell it.
He looked at it, laughed his head off, it
was Jim Henriette, laughed and said, okay,
I said, but just one more thing, when I
deliver the $2,000, I'm a new coming.
I really need a check.
He laughed and said hey, we pay our bills
in 45 days, well knowing that
in advance, I priced my products at 5%
over what I really wanted.
I said I'll tell you what, I'll give you a
5% discount.
Give me a check on the spot, I need the
money.
I already had this in my mind, how do you
get money right away?
Well whatever your price of your product
is up it 5%.
And then give it right back to them for
paying you right away.
To this date, Paul Mitchell gets paid COD
or within ten days.
And we still have the 5% in there, no one
ever doesn't take it.
Hiding in the door she said, okay, and I
drove around back to the warehouse [LAUGH]
Ware house man, this stuff is for you can
I have a check?
He calls Jim Henrietta, we had Jim
Henrietta about ten years
ago at one of our meetings to tell
everyone the story.
This is the same office the phone rings
and my warehouse manager, and he says
your not gonna believe this some guy
loaded products back here, he wants a
check.
He says whats he look like?
It was John Paul, he was just in my office
five minutes ago.
[LAUGH].
Laugh, gave us a check and that's kinda of
how we took off with grass roots.
If we wanted to cross the nation in those
days you could
fly for $99, the midnight special, from
Los Angeles to New York.
Hardly anyone's on that plane.
You pick up the little dividers.
You sleep on it.
And the bathroom is your shower.
So you learn as you go along various ways
to, shall
we say save money and to, along the way,
build the business.
Now I wanna talk to you a little bit about
also, as
you build a business, how to manage it
where you don't lose people.
In 31 years, John Paul Mitchell Systems,
in 87 countries throughout the world, has
had a turnover of less than 30 people,
that's unheard of.
People say, how do I get a job at Paul
Mitchell?
There are no positions, because nobody
wants to leave.
We'll occasionally have a new one with
expansion, but we
treat people the way we want people to
treat us.
So I'd like to take a moment, cuz there's
just
so much to cover in such a short period of
time.
I wanna take just a moment with you to
give you some very important management
techniques, that will
last you for the rest of your life and
maybe some personal techniques on getting
along with people.
I wanna cover with you right now, how to
reprimand somebody if
you're a manager or an owner of a business
whenever you reprimand somebody.
If I went up to this lovely lady here and
told her what she did wrong.
She would feel really bad when we left
each other.
She wouldn't feel good at all.
There's a way to reprimand somebody, where
they feel really good when they leave.
Before you do, you need three things, you
wanna write down
on a piece of paper what is that they did
wrong.
Second of all, you wanna write down so you
know it, how to do it right.
You would be amazed at how many people get
scolded for something, they didn't know
how to do it right, but they won't admit
it how to do it right.
And the third thing is, the last thing the
most important, what do they normally do
really, really good?
What do they normally do really, really
good?
That you could tell them so they feel like
their
really wanted, and they are someone that
you appreciate and respect.
And when they walk out, their happy being
reprimanded.
You know these things, when they call him
and and they come on in.
You always reprimand privately behind
closed doors.
Never reprimand anybody in front of
anybody else.
You do, and that's called for hostility,
they'll
stab you in the back whenever they can.
Only reprimand people behind closed doors
and in private.
First thing you do is you tell them what
it is they did wrong.
The second thing, how to do it right.
I'll give an example, okay?
You come in, every day, on time.
And you're great, people love you.
But when you answer the phone, you're not
smiling.
It's like, hello, can I help you, Stanford
University, or John Paul Mitchell Systems.
If you smile, like we suggested before,
your brightness, your beauty comes across.
And the person on the other end of the
phone knows it's a happy company.
Hi, John Paul Mitchell's System Stanford,
how can I help you?
Big difference, you are incredible, you
come in all the time, people love you.
You bend over backwards to help people
out, because
you're that cool and you do everything
that wonderful,
one would expect you to do this thing also
because you're that, you're that great at
what you do.
She walks out feeling good.
It's the opposite, its the total opposite
for who, a praising somebody.
Whenever somebody did something good,
praise them loudly and
in front of as many people as you can.
Like if there were people walking around
that
worked with you, oh my god you're
unbelievable.
You smile you make people happy on the
other
end of the phone guyz, she is too cool.
And there was, tell them what they did
right in front of a lot of people or make
sure there's someone around so she knows
that someone
else heard what she did right or he did
right.
Very important business the old school
was, I want you to do this, why?
Because I said so.
That is not management.
The worst book ever written in the world,
and it was a best seller 40 years ago.
It was called Management Through
Intimidation,
terrible, terrible [LAUGH] It was a book.
It was a big sell, how could anybody
possibly wanna do that?
And the other thing gets into treating
people how you'd
wanna be treated and not lying about what
you're gonna do.
We're the only major company left in the
professional beauty industry.
I could be two, three times my size, if I
opened up
the Paul Mitchell line to drug stores,
supermarkets, everybody, but I don't.
I go on TV and say, if you ever see Paul
Mitchell in any drug store or supermarket.
It's counterfeit, or it's from the Black
Rate Market.
We don't put it there, don't buy it, even
the
counterfeit bottles say, guaranteed only
when sold in a professional salon.
They really get don't buy it, because we
only sell our product in salons.
That's all black market, grey market or
counterfeit don't
buy it, because we're only in the beauty
industry.
We told hair stylists if we make it,
we're gonna be in the professional beauty
industry forever.
We're never gonna cut you out of the
picture.
We'll never desert you when you build
this, and they did.
So ethics is another good thing, if you
say
you're gonna do something, by gosh, you
wanna do it.
You wanna do it right away.
Another area I wanna to touch on with you
here cuz it's very
helpful, and I know when I was at various
government agencies I would
do some lecturing for some of our agencies
CIA, FBI and I do
a little lecture here and there for the
secret service and other groups.
So, what I lecture on is management
motivation business and
just a lifestyle of being happy so
everyone just feels good.
And I feel that if you're a citizen of any
country and
you wanna change it, by gosh get in there
and motivate people!
If I don't like the way someone is doing
something,
why don't I get in there and talk to their
agents
or talk to their people about another
belief, a new
way to do things be a more loving and
kinda manager.
Where people wanna do more for you, on a
regular basis, and don't want to leave.
There have been times where I've been at
John
Paul Mitchell Systems corporate
headquarters, at five in the
afternoon, 5:30 and half the office's
full, I said
get out of here go home what are you
doing?
Get out of here no, no, we wanna finish
this.
Get out of here no, no JP, it's okay we
wanna finish this because they feel they
are part of it.
And we treat people as they should be
treated.
And there is free lunch by the way,
John Paul Mitchell Systems, everyone gets
free lunch.
We have utensils, so you don't have, so
they're recyclable.
We bring food in big,
different restaurants, in large quantities
recyclable.
If you carpool, we pay for your gas we do
unto others, as we have others do unto us.
And I'm not gonna get religious on you
because I'm not qualified, but my feeling
is,
that if God wanted you to do something,
and if your atheist, let's say nature,
okay?
So I won't get realistic nature, the
universe, let's
just say God for just a good name to use.
What God wants for people is to be happy
and love one
another and treat one another the way you
want to be treated.
Not bashing people, squashing them down,
or killing them
in the name of God he doesn't want that.
He wants all people to be happy and
respect one another not step on anybody.
We have 110 Paul Mitchell schools through
out
the United States, or 15,000 students in
them.
And there's something we have that's
different
than any other school It's called a
culture.
You have to learn the culture while you're
there.
Yes, you will learn [COUGH] if you go to a
Paul Mitchell school.
How to be a great hair stylist.
How to be a great hair cutter.
A great hair colorist.
You will learn all this.
How to merchandise, market, display.
But you'll learn a culture that I think
every university,
every high school, just every school
should teach and they don't.
And the culture is how you love yourself,
people around you.
How to communicate with people you haven't
communicated with in years.
How to break that bound and how to take
care of your
own community, your own state, your own
country, and the whole world.
Everyone that goes to our school
participates for
a couple of months into a fund raising
program.
And if you do really, really well 2,500 of
you get all expenses paid to Las
Vegas for a special training program and a
concert and just a best time in the world.
But when you raise the money, all the
charities we pay for.
Not one dime of the money they raised goes
to anything but the actual charity itself.
Everything from Alzheimer's disease to
helping people Children's Miracle network,
to
feeding orphans in Africa, where their
parents have died of AIDS.
A roundabout thing, well, these students,
and by the way,
last year they raised $1.2 million these
are students, okay?
Will they ever meet the orphans, in
Africa?
No.
Will they ever meet the people who
have Alzheimer's Disease where you're
teaching their family,
or the organization is teaching them how
to
deal with people that are losing their
memory?
No, probably never will.
Will they meet some of these kids that we
help out where they are
not turned down from, for any medical
reason at a hospital, no probably never
will.
But why do they do it?
Because they know, while they are alive
and a
student, and in their life, they can give
back
and change their country and the world for
a
better place to live, because they are
here, somehow participating.
>> [COUGH] Well, and the participation, it
starts with you.
We talked to people about how to love
yourself.
You may come in one day, everything went
wrong, you're really bummed out.
Which happens to everybody we're humans.
Well, here's an affirmation you could
read,
or here's how to talk to another student
or one of the instructors about it or
here's how to do it with yourself.
The biggest one is this and you don't have
to raise your hands because what
I'm gonna tell you is gonna affect more
than 50% of the people in this room.
But I'll tell you about it, I'll tell you
how
to over come it and go forth and be happy.
Many times in life, from your younger
days, your school days, maybe right now.
There may have been someone in your life.
>> [COUGH]
>> It could be your mother, brother,
father, relative,
dear friend, significant other, husband,
wife, something in your life.
There was a communication break.
Some of your life was pretty, pretty close
to her, you wanted to be closer to them.
Something happened, all of a sudden you're
not close to one another anymore,
something happened.
Example is you know, divorces, when you
first met
your husband, your wife, your significant
other, whatever, when you
first met somebody in your life,
boyfriends, girlfriends, they
were the most important person oh, you
couldn't separate us.
But so many months or years later, they
were not liking each other.
Sometimes its in school, sometimes its his
relatives,
it just happens in life because we're
humans.
Now if I were not Kate and [UNKNOWN]
closest [LAUGH] advocate is you here.
If you confront the person, then youre
gonna be human.
Boy you know, you were really wrong in
high school, you passed all
those terrible rumors about me, and that,
you never apologized, you were wrong.
First thing she's gonna do is say
absolutely not,
that's not how it went, look what you did.
People are normally defensive the first
thing
that happens, you're gonna defend your
position.
Its normal, its human, but, were at it
again, how do I break
that bond with my mom, my dad, brother,
sister, uncle, with anybody, [COUGH]
I allow her, to be free enough to tell me
anything she wants.
And the way I do it is this.
We were the best friends, call them on the
phone, or see them face to face either
way.
Hi, we were, I have to talk to you, this
has been on my mind so long.
We were the best of friends, we grew up
together,
grammar school, junior high, high school
and all of a
sudden something happened, whatever I did,
whatever I said or
did to offend you, please forgive me
that's not me.
I'm a different person, that's not me.
Will you please forgive me for whatever I
may have
said or done that offended you, please
that's not me.
Well-.
In half the cases, the other person says
oh my God I'm so
glad you called me, oh my God I've been
wanna call you for years.
It wasn't you, it was me.
Let's talk, and you cry, you're happy, you
have coffee or tea or
shot a patron together or something,
[LAUGH] or shampoo your hair with vomit.
In other words, something, almost on, you
allowed the bond to be broken.
If you do this with people, 90% of all
people are gonna respond and say, oh my
gosh, I'm so glad she called me, yeah,
this went wrong, let's talk about it, what
happened?
And, in many cases it was, somebody said
something to you about someone else, that
wasn't true.
There was this great book written called
The Four Agreements.
Four ways to live your life, and I believe
it was the second agreement and
the author Don Miguel Ruiz, R-U-I-Z, the
second
agreement was never gossip or listen to
gossip.
Because if you listen to gossip and tell
somebody else,
all of a sudden they'll tell somebody
else, it spreads.
Now you find out, what you were told was
not true.
Now do you go back to everyone said, no,
that, that wasn't true.
Tell everybody you told that was a lie.
Somebody told me a rumor.
You can't.
It's out of control.
Don't pass gossip or ever listen to
gossip.
It may not be true.
And you're not gonna live a happy life if
you do that.
And you know people in your lives that,
you know, just wanna
tell you all the scoop, all the bad stuff
that's going on.
Well that's your choice.
You can hang out with people that want to
yell
the bad stuff, or hang out with people who
want
tell the good stuff on how to make things
better
in life as opposed to all that's going on
wrong.
So, look at how cool our lives are, look
at all that's going on wrong there.
Also what does giving, give you?
If you give to somebody, they never says
thank you,
never knows you did it, what is your
reward for it?
I'd like to give you a little example of
philanthropy.
When I was six years old, I grew up my
mother, my brother and I.
We group at Echo Park, LA.
Downtown, LA.
We had very, very little.
We had food on the table, two changes of
clothes.
Extra t-shirt, pair of shoes every week.
Same pair though.
[LAUGH] Until they had holes in 'em.
We never had a lot, but we never knew it.
When I was six years old my mom took my
brother and I to downtown Los Angeles.
They had trolley cars in those days, five
cents.
This is early 1950s.
Trade the trolley car for a nickel and
then.
At Christmas time there'd be all these
fine
department stores Bullocks, Macy's, these
beautiful department stores
and these giant windows they'll have all
these
cool Christmas decorations, puppets that
move, trains going around.
And my mom one day, took ten cents and
gave
it to my brother and I, and said boys,
each one
of you hold this and together walk up with
this dime
and put in the bucket of that guy ringing
the bell.
We did.
Went back and said, mom, why did we give
that guy?
Ringing down the bucket, ten cents, that's
three candy
bars, two coca-colas, remember this is the
early 50s.
Okay?
That was a lot of money.
Right?
And my mom said to us, boys it's to let
you know something in life.
No matter how bad off you think you are.
There's always someone worse off than you.
That's the Salvation Army.
And those people really hurt.
Most don't have places to live, and people
have to feed them.
So it's a good thing son.
So that kind of stuck in the mind.
But I'll give you the example of the most
ultimate high.
Now, I'm older than you guys.
Most of you are probably born in the 60s
and 70s.
Well, I was there in the 60s.
[LAUGH] A little different environment.
I'm gonna give an example of the ultimate
high.
[LAUGH] Paul Mitchel.
[LAUGH]
>> I didn't say any, I'm just gonna give
you an example of the ultimate high.
Okay?
That's all.
Didn't say I did anything.
[LAUGH] Okay.
I didn't say I didn't, I didn't say
anything okay.
But the ultimate high, it took, and a lot
of people ask this too.
When did you know Paul Mitchel hair care
products, John Paul Mitchel systems was
gonna be successful.
Two years after I started the company,
because two years after I
started was the first time, we could pay
our bills on time.
Didn't pay them off, but paid them on
time, it took that long.
Every week was please the check's in the
mail don't
cut me off, I"ll hand deliver it the day
after tomorrow.
Oh no I sent it to the wrong address.
In other words, it was miserable.
I could remember not sleeping at night cuz
I couldn't pay my bills.
Did it help?
No, but I didn't sleep anyways.
It was just oh god.
So it was a big deal.
Every week for almost two years, we should
of gone out of business.
If you fill, follow a textbook how to do
things.
You would say, guys, go bankrupt, go
bankrupt, go bankrupt.
You just, there's no hope for you.
You can't even pay your bills.
And the black and white, of course, was
two
cents, opposed to the seven cents for the
color.
When we hired our first person, one person
a year and a half later.
That's when we had our first employee in
the field.
Had to do ten jobs.
So we built a company with fewer moving
parts.
So, two years later, our bills are finally
paid on time.
We have $2,000 in the bank each.
We immediately took a dividend and felt on
top of the world.
Oh my God, it's 1982 now, our bills are
paid on time, we have $2,000 each.
So I'm gonna do something I've never done
in my life when I went to a restaurant.
I went to El Torito Marina del Rey.
It's a chain of restaurants all over the
place, and I went down there
and if you look at a menu, well, here,
when you open a menu up.
Right?
Okay, here it shows you what you get and
over here on the right side, is the price.
Well if I ever went to a restaurant, I
would go to the price
first, see what you got, came over here
and see what you get for it.
Worth how much, is it 395 okay.
So this time, okay, I'm going to El
Torito.
I'm, and I took a friend with me, and I'm
gonna
order anything I want, of the left side of
the menu.
Carne de asada, you know, big margarita,
didn't have Patron yet, but was okay.
[LAUGH]
>> Big margarita, big order of guacamole,
you know.
Woo, cool.
So I'm with my friend there, corner of the
room there, top of the world.
In front of me, is a table of 12 children,
one Hispanic lady
at one end, one Afro American lady at the
other end, with her back
to me, and all these children,
Caucasian, Asian, black, white,
everything, every color,
there was like a rainbow sitting there,
and they were from the inner city.
I knew, cuz I'm from the inner city, I
knew
how they dressed you know, I you could
just tell.
Well, the mom held it up like the said
menu and did what I was doing before.
395, what do you get?
It was obvious that they had a very
limited budget, she
was holding vulnerable children there, and
it was someone's special day.
I don't know what made me do this.
It just did.
I got up, I walked into the kitchen,
efforted calculations, okay 12,
13, 14 they pick out what's the most it's
gonna cost them.
I came to 200 somewhat dollars okay.
Now then I got 2000 in the bank, a
credit card, I walked into the kitchen
after the waiter,
and I said those kids sitting in front of
me,
those two moms, tell them to order
anything they want.
Tell them the bill is gonna be picked up
and the tip's gonna be picked up.
Anything they want, but don't tell them
who's doing it.
Now, I don't why I said that.
I don't know why I followed indication.
It was just the thing to do.
Sometimes in life, the thing to do comes
at you.
If it does, do it, just do it.
Don't question, just do it.
As long as it doesn't hurt anybody, came
up.
I went and sat down.
And, he told the lady.
And, this lady must have been an
evangelist, big woman with an angelic
voice.
She stood up, she was about that far from
me, stood up, turned around, looked at me.
Can't be this guy.
Slowly looked around, slowly looked around
the entire restaurant.
Maybe it took her half a minute.
It was that slow.
And that's a long time to look around a
restaurant.
And ended up with me, not this guy
obviously.
And I was, you know, not even looking at
her.
Anyway, she stands up with her back to me
maybe two feet from me.
Her arms raised in the most angelic voice.
She must have led a choir or something.
And she said, loudly in this restaurant,
whoever you are.
God bless you, you have no idea what doing
for me and these children!
The place went silent looked at her, God
thank you and sat down.
As she did that, goose bumps ran up, in
fact when
ever I tell the story there's still goose
bumps, they run up
and down my arms, these ran over my body,
I was high
as a kite oh, my God did I feel like I
was.
Wow, this must be what heaven is like.
I did something for somebody else, never
asked
anything in return, she still did never
knew.
When I walked out, I felt so unbelievable
that day and the next day.
And what made me feel good was, I did what
humans should do, something for somebody
else asking nothing in return.
Your, your reward far exceeds any thank
you.
You know you did it, you know you
wanted nothing in return, but doing
something while
you're on the planet earth, to make it
a better place to live, because you are
here.
Now, I know we're limited for time, and I
wanna have sometime for questions here.
So, let me open this up now, and as you
know, I'm in a variety of businesses.
But from, we did start, by the way, 21
years ago.
We started Patron, I'll tell you that just
real fast.
We wanted to give the world the finest
mellowest tequila on the planet.
So my partner Mr.Crowly and I, put this
together, went down there and
Patron is made out of the finest
highlander blue agave that ever existed.
When we started the company, it was so
expensive to make it, we
knew America wanted to treat itself, with
something that was good and mellow.
Not holding your breath when you drink
tequila.
We wanted something that was higher end,
that
once you drank it, you'd wanna reorder it.
Big problem.
The most expensive tequila's then were 5,
6, 7, $10, maybe $14 a bottle.
It was so expensive to make patron, we had
to
sell it for 35 to 37.95 a bottle in 1998.
Who's gonna pay that?
It was the best.
People started drinking and, wow, I don't
have to hold my breath anymore.
I can drink this straight.
Wow.
I'm not hung over the next day.
If you drink the whole bottle, you're
gonna get hung over, but, regardless.
It's not the same as regular tequila.
I wanna treat myself.
And it slowly grew.
We were the first to introduce what you
call a high
end ultra premium tequila ever throughout
the United States of America.
Today Patron is the number one ultra
premium tequila in the world.
We're in 120 countries.
109 rap songs and hip-hop songs have been
written about Patron.
Three country western songs and two pop
songs, okay.
We don't pay for any of this, it's in lots
of movies.
But people appreciate it.
One, it was the best quality, it was the
finest, and still is today.
It is the finest tequila you could ever
buy today, and the best, we think for your
body, and we even use our distillage and
make it into fertilizer, instead of
polluting the land.
That's how we feel about it.
And of course it's also the second largest
selling tequila
in the world even know it's the
highest-end ultra premium.
If you take all the inexpensive ones,
combine them
all together, we're number two in the
world by bottle.
Number one by far is, the top ultra
premium.
Highest quality there was, finest
packaging,
but more important, we also give back.
Not only do we make Patron, in the old
fashioned way, in little stills.
But, we have an orphanage down there, I
have an old folks
home down there, we're rebuilding houses
for the St. Bernard Project in Louisiana.
Our staff goes down there to help rebuild
houses.
We believe in giving back and giving a lot
of love.
Do you have any questions or comments,
because I could be here for hours
with you going through all the companies,
what we did, how we started it.
But, let's take a few minutes with you,
any comments, criticisms, any
questions you have on anything I might be
able to answer for you?
Anybody?
Hands?
There you go.
There's, start with you, sir.
>> Everybody just wait for a mic.
>> You even have a mic.
>> Mic comes down to them for the
recording.
>> So I hear a lot of people that have
your entrepreneur's story, where they sold
encyclopedias, or they, I mean, what do we
do today that's the equivalent of selling
encyclopedias door-to-door.
What's something street-smart that we can
all do?
Anything you want to sell, any idea, any
product,
whatever it is, just go out and do it.
That's the equivalent of selling something
new door-to-door.
[LAUGH] l did encyclopedia.
You know?
And they don't have door-to-door sales of
encyclopedia's anymore.
If they did, every one of my kids would be
forced to
do that for at least six months, no matter
how they did.
If I have to subsidize them just for
the experience, I would say it's, it's
anything, anything.
If you want the experience of going
door-to-door, why don't you go and make up
a little booklet or make up an information
packet on what you're starting right now.
Take two or three or four pages, do a
whole report on what you're doing, and go
door-to-door and say, hi I'm a student you
know, here at Stanford University this is
five pages.
I want people to know about the subject,
it's only one dollar you know,
here's what it is the dollar goes to me it
helps with the education.
I think it's interesting and here's why.
That's one example.
Selling yourself and your idea.
Just one example.
You wanna just test it out.
But I think, if you say you're a student
from Stanford, they'll probably be a
little more accommodating.
You know, opposed to, hey, I have this
bushel of potatoes.
And I bought it for $5, but I'm gonna let
you have it for four.
It's the best potato in the world, you
know?
In other words, your own idea, your own
thoughts,
is a great way to get started on anything.
Or grab some charity, any charity that you
firmly believe in, and just go knocking on
doors.
Hi I wanna tell you a little bit about
Food for Africa, I wanna
tell you a little bit about Kids Play New
Park here in Palo Alto, anything.
Just need experience.
Yes sir?
>> Thanks for talking to us today when you
were losing money in your first business,
what I guess.
What was the threshold at which you said,
after this point I am going to declare
bankruptcy when everyone said you should
be declaring
bankruptcy right away and what kep you
going?
>> Okay, we started losing money from day
one.
But, I knew, that if I could tell enough
hair
dressers about this product and get them
to use it.
It was better than anything they'd ever
used in
their life, and they'd wanna continue to
use it.
It was just how many people could I talk
to?
And keep on chasing the bill collector,
you know, and
at the same time, you know, get the job
done.
I believed enough in it.
Four months later, we invented something
called Skullfine lotion.
And it became a trend two years later.
So you put this lotion on, it didn't
flake.
You had the wet look, or you brushed it
out and you had the dry, fluffy look.
Or, if you had straight hair, you'd put it
on, put
waves in your hair, let it dry, they would
stay there.
Brush your hair, the waves are still
there.
Rinse it out, they'd disappear instantly,
no build up.
But, nobody knew it, it was all word of
mouth, word of mouth.
So, we knew, that we wanted to be in the,
reorder business.
So I knew, I would tell enough people.
We'd be able to keep up with our supply,
goes we had no money.
Every dime we had that came in, was
inventoried.
And since we had no inventory, it was hand
to mouth, hand to mouth, hand to mouth.
But we believe what we were in and we knew
it.
Cuz the first few people re-order.
We just didn't have a lot of customers, we
had to get out there and do it.
Hope that answers your question okay for
you.
Questions?
Comments?
Criticisms?
Yes sir?
>> So [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yes.
>> And you didn't, you don't remember
[COUGH] that
experience, so why did he take chances on
you?
>> Well, I was in the beauty industry
working
for major companies for nine years, and I
started
out as a sales person with one company and
became their national manager in a year
and a half.
So, then I got into marketing, so it was
obvious in sales and
marketing in the professional beauty
industry I knew exactly what I was doing.
There was no doubt in his mind.
>> So [INAUDIBLE]
>> Very good.
How to size up your partner, very
important.
Whether it's your family, your friends, or
somebody you
never met the first thing is feel the
energy.
How many people year round you just feel
uncomfortable around them?
You get somebody like that, that's not
your partner.
Yeah, when you feel that, the, the
universe,
the, the the frequency of this planet is
rising
right now and more and more people can
feel
other people out a lot quicker than ever
before.
First thing is, if you feel odd around
somebody, that's not your partner.
Next thing is, write down a piece of
paper.
Here's what you bring to the partnership.
What can the other person bring to the
partnership, other than just money, if it
is money.
And where's what influence what can they
do to help
build your business and, how are they
planning to do it.
Interview them, like you interview them
for a position, a partner.
What can you bring to it and why do you
like this?
Why do you think we're gonna make it
together?
What are you willing to do?
And do we like each other?
Also, go to breakfast or lunch with them.
Go to breakfast or lunch with, hang out a
little bit.
Just don't rely on interviews.
Sometimes you have breakfast and you've
lunch or dinner.
You get to know the person.
You get to see them in a
social environment, not just your business
environment.
So get to know them first and get that
feeling
for that person, what they gonna bringing
to the table.
Is it synergistic?
Synergism meaning one plus one doesn't
equal two.
It equals three, four, five, or 20.
Is that gonna happen?
When the two of you together is gonna be a
synergistic thing where you each bring
something to one another.
And you know you like each other.
If you don't like each other, that's not
your partner.
If they're a mean person, that's not your
partner.
If when you're talking to them, they
criticize other people, that's not your
partner.
They don't believe in a nice positive way
of life, that's not your partner.
If they're not honest, that's not your
partner.
They don't wanna make the world a better
place to live, that's not your partner.
[COUGH] If they're not exciting, that's
not your partner.
And you don't have to be an extrovert to
be excited, you just have
to believe what you're doing is really
cool and you have like a quiet excitement.
[LAUGH] [INAUDIBLE] excited.
Any other questions?
Yes.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> What's your name?
>> How many entrepreneurial success that
were preceded by emotional and financial
hardship.
>> Yes.
>> I'm assuming that you've had several
others that have proved unsuccessful and
I'd
like to know what your internal dialogue
was like throughout those, you know
ventures.
And what you told yourself to kind of keep
going.
>> Okay, well in using that, let me give
you a
better example to answer your question of
things that weren't successful.
I was in my car, there was no money.
And what little money we had, $700,
between
Paul and I that paid for the silkscreener,
period.
I had no money.
I went to my mom, did not tell her how
things were, except I was doing well.
I had a nice house on Mulholland Drive.
I said Mom, could I borrow a few 100 bucks
right now, I'm just short with cash.
Oh sure son, everything okay.
Yeah, it's fine.
And the big failure was how am I gonna eat
and sleep for the
next couple of weeks while I'm selling
this and the stuffs coming into sell.
How am I gonna exist?
That was the biggest challenge of them all
and, I knew no matter what
I'll some how figure a way to get by this
one no matter what.
I slept in my car for two weeks.
I showered at Griffith Park, they had
public showers
down there, for 99 cents, I went to the
Freeway Cafe, you find these things out
when you're
really hurting, you know, how do you
overcome this problem.
Went to the Freeway Cafe for 99 cents,
after
9 o'clock they wanted people to come by,
truckers.
So, they give you egg egg, one piece of
toast or sausage or bacon, and one glass
of juice or coffee and you will tell so, I
had one egg, sausage was a bigger one.
One sausage, one piece of toast, one
orange juice that was my breakfast.
When you come the afternoon, you will get
hungry.
Well, at a lot of these big places, these
big chains, to get
people come in there and order at 4:30 to
6 o'clock they've heavy hour.
99 cents, any well drink you want.
So I'd go in there for 99 cent margarita
and they also had food to keep you there.
And I'll tell you what about 20 chicken
wings later and whole bunch
of salsa you had your vegetables your full
meal and you're feeling good.
[LAUGH] And then, so that's how I survived
and put some gas in the
car and got this business going until the
first sale was able to be made.
Along the way other little businesses that
I started one was
a consulting business a year before I
started John Paul Mitchell Systems.
I was a consultant I knew the beauty
industry
inside and out if I went to you and you
could pay me I told you everything you had
to
know in three months then you didn't need
me anymore.
I was out of a job.
If you really needed me badly, I was
running your company for
you and it was two to three weeks behind
trying to pay me.
That was going nowhere, so I moved onto
something else.
Also, since Paul Mitchell and of course
Patron Tequila, John Paul Pin,
other ventures, I've started other little
things that didn't quite work as well.
But, I did have Paul Mitchell there you
know, as my
back [UNKNOWN] so wasn't really a thing
that was overly challenging.
The biggest one was Paul Mitchell and
eating and finding a
place to sleep, which was my car in
existing for a couple
of weeks and still put your jacket on and
your stuff in
the car to deliver where nobody knows
you're really down and out.
That was really the tough one.
But I believe what we did was right.
There was a young lady here first then
we'll get you sir.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Yes.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Correct.
>> [INAUDIBLE] rinse the-.
>> The conditioner in your hair is a leave
in conditioner.
Yes.
>> Can you tell us a little bit about how
that played
in to the timing of that, and the
innovation of these firms and.
>> Absolutely, that's a great question.
>> All part of a movement-
>> You got it.
Yeah.
>> Basically, and you were in the timing.
>> The timing was incredible, because here
you had people, and
salons that had a, perms were a deal in
those days.
Had to perm people's hair for example.
And yet people backed up.
So we looked at, what does salon need?
Well maybe we'll cut some time there.
One shampoo instead of too.
And you pick up another ten minutes if
you're
not rinsing and putting the conditioner on
the back basin.
So that's time and money.
That's unique.
Also as you said about perms during the
time, and blow drying.
People were perming and blow drying,
perming
and blow drying and just ruining their
hair.
And when they had perms, this leave in
conditioner, you could leave in your hair
as a
perm, when it dried instead of freaking
out of
you, it was under controlling all the
curls in.
So the timing had a lot to do with it too
it was a good time.
It was a good time to come in.
We saw the need in the marketplace.
Find the need in the marketplace that
someone else didn't find and push that.
Or find the need in the marketplace that
no one else is promoting and promote it.
Yes, sir, you've got a question over
here.
>> This will be the final one.
>> Okay.
>> I wanted to, I wanted to commend your,
your attrition rate
with your employees, but can you speak a
little bit about employee selection?
>> Sure.
First thing I do when we interview people
and up
until a year ago I interviewed everybody,
but now we're
getting pretty big in a few countries so I
have
to rely on my president to do some
interviewing with me.
But it's just what I told this other young
man about finding a partner.
If I'm interviewing you, the first thing
I'm gonna do
is, I'll have your resume in front of me
but I'm
not going for your resume, I'm going for
how I feel
about your and the energy that's coming
from you to me.
I'm going for the soul.
Not for this thing the soul's occupying
and not the resume you filled out.
I'll look at the resume and refer to
various things on the resume.
I go straight towards the person.
One girl, for example, that heads up part
of my research and my trademarking
department, I went
to the promona mall and she was there
at Christmas time for charity trying to
raise money.
She was the happiest, most incredible lady
I, young lady.
20 years old I'd ever met.
Oh, how ya doing?
Oh, we have this charity here.
And you don't have to give us a lot of
money.
But on your way out if you wanna give us a
quarter or anything.
It helps the kids.
I could not belive this personality.
As I left I said, if your ever interested,
boy do
I have a job for you at John Paul Mitchel
Systems.
Yeah, I don't have a job right now, other
than helping charities.
She was my receptionist.
Her personality was so overwhelming.
That year, we gave everybody bonuses in
the year.
That year, she got one of the biggest
bonuses in the company.
And she was a receptionist because of what
she is.
I go for the person.
I go right for the person, the soul.
How do I feel about that person?
Then I go into some of the necessities
that we might need for the job.
You know, some of the things that, that,
you know, can you use a computer?
You know, can you talk on the phone?
You know what I mean?
Can you write?
[LAUGH] You know what I mean?
We go towards, you know, the things with
the technical things for the
first thing is, I go for that soul, I go
for the entity.
Again the frequency of the planet is
raising.
People are becoming more aware and you
say, well how can you prove this?
I will prove it to you in one statement.
Per capital, cuz lot more people on this
planet never was before, per capital
there are more individuals and groups into
philanthropic endeavors.
Or what can I do to help the planet and
others out more than ever
in the history of this planet, per
capital, not just because of a large
population.
Frequency has something to do with it.
Think of you when you watch TV or
listening to the news, or
you read things and books years ago, they
have changed, it aren't so true.
I you, wait a minute, that's not right,
I'm
gonna challenge this, why is this the way
it is?
I don't think that's right.
Maybe, you know, we even believe in the
[UNKNOWN], maybe there's
something else that could be true, like
the world is flat.
No, I think it's round.
I'm gonna sail around it.
The frequency is rising and more and more
people are going for it.
They say 2012 and I'll finish in five, ten
seconds.
2012 Mayan calendar said worlds gonna
collapse.
Look whats going on in the middle east.
Explosions.
Armageddon, bla, bla, bla.
I think whats going to happen in 2012 is
the frequency is rising
and people are becoming so aware that all
peoples are saying this is wrong.
This is right.
We want more of what's right.
And we don't mind helping one another out.
One of the biggest things that ever
happened on television a week and a half
ago, was in Egypt, after they took over
their own government, there was a day.
I've never seen anything like this.
No one could ever imagine it.
There was a day there where Christians and
Muslims were together.
They made a flag of the Christian cross
and the Muslim symbol and they said we're
reuniting
together as Christians and Muslims, we
both want
our freedom and we're going forth together
as one.
Whatever you believe in you believe in.
My way may be different from yours but
we're to gonna kill you or we're not
gonna degrade you because of it, and it
was all over the streets all over the
news.
And I thought wow they should have ran
that for many may days not just one day.
The frequency of our planet is changing.
It's going in a great direction so you
have some good things [SOUND] to look
forward to.
Thank you for taking your time to be here
with
me and give me a chance to chat with you.
[SOUND]